- Hi everyone.
My name is Anuradha Kumari
and today we are here to talk about inaccessibility
in websites and relation of JavaScript with it.
Before we start, little bit of introduction about myself.
My name is Anuradha Kumari.
I'm working as a development specialist at Mediaocean.
I'm really passionate about JavaScript and accessibility.
My handle, Twitter handle is miracle_404
So if you would like to talk about anything
from JavaScript accessibility
to other technologies in general,
you can reach out to me and I will be happy to help.
What are we going to cover today?
Today we will start
with a basic introduction of accessibility
and dive into why it is important
and some of the demos and examples
of how JavaScript can make or break accessibility.
The first and foremost question
is, what exactly is accessibility?
Accessibility means making resources and services
usable by everyone regardless of their ability
or disability.
Why do we care?
Why is accessibility so important?
To understand that we must first understand
why did we really create websites or applications.
We create them so that the users can use them.
Now, if some of the features are not accessible by users,
they can not use them.
So accessibility actually equals usability.
If the user cannot use them,
what is the motive of creating a website or application?
As Tim Berners-Lee the creator of Web has rightly told
that the power of the Web is in its universality
and access by everyone, regardless of disability
is an essential aspect.
If we think about accessibility, it's not a new concept.
It has always been there since the beginning of Web.
World's first website is totally accessible.
If you go ahead and check it out,
this is the world's first website
and I'm using one of the assistive technology,
which is keyboard.
And I can totally navigate to all the links
using just my keyboard.
So we do not really know about our user,
that how they're going to use our website
or what they could be going through
when are using our website.
So it highly advice advisable
that we should always keep it accessible.
World Health Organization or WHO says that
15% of world's population lives with some kind of disability
Let's see through
what are the different kinds of disability,
which our users can be living with.
Like there are different categories,
permanent, temporary and situational.
To take an example of a sight disability,
if a user is blind, it's a permanent disability.
But another user might be having some
infection in their eyes.
And they're still not able to see something.
Then it's called temporary disability.
Then there comes a situation that our eyes are totally fine,
but we are in a bright environment
and we are not able to see what is on our screen.
We are not able to navigate on our tablets, on our mobile
then this is called situational disability.
Apart from that,
there are people who have some cognitive
or neurological condition.
They face some difficulty in understanding the content,
or they might feel uneasy when see animation
or time-sensitive content.
Then there are users
who might be facing some technical challenges
like they are accessing our websites
on a slow internet connection or an older technology
or on a smaller screen device.
So is our website accessible
for all of these kinds of users?
Also there are certain issues which come with aging
like a sight issues or motor disabilities and so on.
There could also be a situation where our user
is in panic mode or stress.
So have we made our website easily structured
and navigable by such kind of users?
We must always think about these things.
So by now, I might have convinced you
to understand that, okay, accessibility is important.
And we must be thinking about accessibility
when we're creating websites and applications.
So you might ask, "Well, how do I start with accessibility?"
My first advice is that we must always think about users.
We must think from user perspective what the user needs
or what is the issue we are trying to resolve.
If we are thinking from user perspective,
then we have already taken a big step towards accessibility.
Apart from that, there are certain resources on internet,
which contain very good information about accessibility.
You should go ahead and read it and see what we require
and there are official websites for W3C
and MDN also has a very good documentation on accessibility.
And they have rules, which suggests that
if we are using a certain kind of component,
how user can navigate through them
and how we can make them more accessible.
Normally when we we talk about accessibility
we always talk about HTML and CSS.
We think about the rules
through which we can make our websites more accessible.
But today we are going to focus on JavaScript
and see how writing good JavaScript
can really make websites more accessible.
We are going through some of the rules
and we will see some examples
of how we can create highly accessible websites.
The rule number one is using semantic HTML.
Semantic HTML tags are the tags
which have some meaning attached to them.
They do not affect the presentation of our website,
but they contain the information
which is used by the assistive technologies
and which is used by the users
who are suffering from some kind of disability
or [other] users also sometimes.
So we are going to see one classic example
of div versus button.
When we are trying to introduce interactivity
within our website,
button is one of the things which we use
so that a user can go ahead and trigger some action on it.
But there are multiple ways to create a button,
we can even use a div or span to create a button
and make it look and feel like button,
or we can use 'button',
which is a semantic tag for interactivity.
Let's go ahead and see what is the difference
and how it can affect the accessibility.
So before that,
this is one of the websites which I have created
to help spread awareness around accessibility.
And it contains some of the basic examples now
around accessibility.
So let's go and check out the button example.
For button, if we go ahead and see, these are the buttons,
button one and button three,
which I have created using button semantic tag
but the second button is created using div.
Now as a mouse user,
I can go ahead and click on any of them
and it will work perfectly fine,
but let's try to navigate it through our keyboard.
Keyboard users use tab key to navigate
through the interactive elements.
So I will click on tab.
I go to button one perfectly fine.
Now I want to do something
which can happen on click on button two.
So I will tab again, because I want to go to button two.
I tab over it, but I cannot access button two.
I directly went to button three.
So by using div tag, what I have done,
is that I have essentially blocked my keyboard users
out of the flow.
They cannot access my button
so they can not trigger that action.
They can not perform the action.
So it's not a good user experience, right?
We have blocked the user
from what they came on our website to do.
So to fix that, there are two options,
the first one is obviously using a semantic button tag,
but in case there is a situation
where we are not using a semantic HTML,
and we still can go ahead and add some code
to make it more semantic.
So how you can do that [is]--
before that let's see the example for that.
So if you go through the accessible button
example, I am tabbing on it and I can go ahead and tab
and now button two is focused.
So user can go ahead and perform the action
through keyboard as well.
And so I'm trying to click on it using keyboard,
and I'm able to do that too.
So, wow we have just made it accessible
for different kinds of users and all users are happy.
So how to do that?
So first rule is using a tab index.
Using tab index, what we do,
we make any non semantic HTML focusable.
And then to make it interact well by our keyboard,
we need to add event listener to it.
So in this case we are using a keydown event listener.
So if we go ahead and see the code for it,
it's the div, which is acting as a button.
And I have provided tab and next zero roll up button
because I want to let the screen readers
and other assistive technologies know that
there is a button which they have encountered.
Now what I do, I'm finding the button to get element by ID.
We find out the button
and we still need to add event listener using click
because the actions will happen
when we're clicking on that button.
Extra thing which we need to do now
is that we need to add a keydown event listener
as well to that button,
because this is required for keyboard accessibility.
Now keydown will be fired every time user presses, any key
so we need to check for the specific keys.
So as part of accessibility rules,
a user can either press the space key or the enter key
to trigger any action.
So what I will do,
I will check if the key pressed by user
was space or enter.
If yes, I'm going ahead and again doing the action,
which is supposed to be done on the click of that button.
Apart from that one more thing which we need to do is
that we need to prevent a default behavior of the click,
of the event.
So this is required because when you click on space,
when you press the space button by default
the screen scrolls.
We want to prevent that action for the button.
That's why we will use this preventDefault to block that.
So we just saw how using a semantic HTML tag
enhances accessibility.
And if we don't want to use that,
or in any case, if we are using a non semantic HTML,
how by writing that extra JavaScript code,
we have just enhanced the accessibility
and it is now usable by any kind of user.
So rule number two is all the functionality
must be accessible through keyboard.
We saw one of the examples here.
So what other interactions
[do] users performs using keyboards?
The first one obviously navigating through the elements.
We can trigger any actions, submit any form,
or you can exit any current component.
So like if there's a pop over on it
and using just key press I would like to exit
that dialogue or that modal from that screen.
One of the examples could be
when we have any horizontal scroll
or next or previous buttons on our website,
in that case, we do want to add arrow key event handling
so that the users who are using keyboard,
they can press the arrow keys
and they should be able to scroll
or navigate to next and previous content on the website.
The important keys that user presses are enter, space bar,
tab, and escape.
And we must always remember the key values for it,
so that we can go ahead and add event listeners
as and when required.
This is a sample code of how we can add an event listener
to any element of our website.
Rule number three is that
event listeners, which we just saw an example of,
they should be device independent.
What do we mean by that?
So JavaScript has many event handlers,
there are many like mouseup, mousedown, mouseover,
keyup, keydown.
So why do we want to do that?
Whenever we want them to trigger any action,
we must use keyup or keydown
in place of mouseup and mousedown
because mouseup and mousedown
are device dependent event listeners.
So they will be only accessed through mouse.
So if I have a button and I have a task, a mouse upon it,
then I can click on it only using mouse.
If I do want other users to access that trigger action
or access that button and click over it,
I should be adding the keyup or keydown event handlers
in that case.
Now, if there is any business requirement
or any such a condition
where we really want to have mousedown and mouseup event
for some of our elements,
we must also include a complimentary keyup
or keydown event listener
so that we are not blocking the assistive technology users
out of our flow.
Rule number four is managing focus.
So we must manage the focus on our website.
Well, what do we mean by focus?
So focus is actually something like, you know,
it has a very bad reputation of seemingly ugly outline
over the interactive elements.
So if you see here in this button,
there is this a black outline.
And if we're in dark mode,
it has this white outline by default.
And what happens in general that many designers suggest
or many developers also,
we do not like this on our element by default.
So what we do, we go ahead and hide it.
And when we hide it,
as a mouse user we are still able
to navigate perfectly fine.
But when it comes to the users who rely only on keyboard
for navigating through our elements,
we have just blocked them out
because they're not able to understand
what is the current active element
on their web page right now.
So to understand this better, I have created some demos.
So the first demo will be,
where what we are doing, that I have hidden the outline.
So which we normally do.
So if you see I'm using my mouse
and I'm perfectly able to go anywhere on this website,
and I know that where I am currently and I can click on it
and it will work.
But now as a keyboard user, if I'm a keyboard user now,
and I will try to navigate it only through my keyboard,
if you see, the outline,
it never comes on the web content.
So I'm not able to access any of the links or buttons
on this website.
So it's a very bad user experience for keyboard users.
So now, normally what happens that we say this,
we give this example, we preach about this,
we think about it and then we forget.
The next time again, we might be doing the same thing.
Unless we are in the situation
where we are blocked due to such behavior.
So one such a behavior for a mouse user
could be that the cursor is not there, right?
So what I have done here now is effectively,
this content is totally accessible by a other keyboards.
So if you go out and see
through keyboard I'm able to access everything,
but as a mouse user,
so my cursor is there now,
and now I want to perform something using my mouse.
So if you see the cursor's invisible now,
just like I had outlined in the previous example,
I have just hidden cursor in this example.
And I am not sure where I am on this webpage,
so I'm not able to do anything.
So I highly suggest you to go through this a small example
and see for yourself how frustrating it is
if we do not understand where we are currently.
So we cannot proceed to do the action
which we came to do here.
It's highly frustrating.
It really helps us to understand that if we hide outline,
or if we do not provide users with any measures
to understand which is their current active element,
how frustrating it could be for the users--
it's such a bad user experience.
Now what we're going to do.
This is one of my favorite quote,
I read it somewhere and I really liked it.
"Outline is to keyboard users,
what cursor is to mouse users." And this is so true.
This really relates so much.
So what we're going to do today,
we are going to see one of the use cases where
using JavaScript will really enhance the accessibility
of our website.
That use case is modal interaction.
Whenever we are having a dialogue on our website,
how can we use JavaScript to make it highly accessible
for any kind of user?
Let's jump back again to the examples.
We go back to our website and modals. Here we are.
So what I'm going to do,
I am directly going to use my keyboard
to access to all of these.
And so what is the behavior of an inaccessible website
and then how we can make it accessible.
I'm using my tab.
I came on the button, which is going to open my modal.
I entered on it, the modal opened.
But now if you notice one thing,
the focus, which we just talked about.
The focus is still on the back of the modal.
It's still on the view, which is now not active.
The modal is active now,
but the focus is in back off it.
So the user wanted the focus shifted to the modal,
which clearly didn't happen. That's okay.
I click on tab again. Still the focus does not come here.
So it's confusing to the user.
However, if the user clicks on tab, two, three times,
it will come after the flow of interactive elements
reaches the modal, it will still come to the modal.
Now the focus is there on the modal
and we can perform an interaction.
What I want to do,
maybe there was a form or something,
I want to go ahead and submit.
But let's say I'm tabbing here
and by mistake, I tabbed one more time.
So the normal behavior or the accessibility rule,
it says that the focus must be trapped
into the active container right now, the active modal,
which is where the focus should have been
in this modal itself.
It should not have moved out.
But what happened right now
that the focus moved out of this modal
and went again back to the modal.
This again confuses the users.
However, I can use shift tab again,
and I can come back to this modal.
Now the third rule says that,
if a modal has opened,
or if we have a close icon or something like that,
the user must be able to close that modal using a keyboard,
using the escape button on keyboard.
So I tried to click on escape, but the modal will not close.
I have to go back to the cross icon and that button,
and then I can click either enter or space
and now the modal is closed.
So we see that user has to perform some extra steps.
And there were some steps which really confused the users.
And we are not clearly following
all the rules of accessibility while creating this modal.
So let's see how accessible modals should behave.
So if you go to the third button, click here to open modal,
this is going to open accessible modal.
Let's see, I click enter on it.
And if you see the modal is open
and the focus came right to the first interactive element
in this modal,
which means that user now knows that,
okay, we are in the modal,
focus is in the modal and I can go ahead
and perform any action.
Now I'm pressing tab.
It came to the last interactive element of modal.
I press tab again.
And it went back to the first interactive element
on the modal.
So this is called focus trapping.
Whenever the user presses tab or shift tab,
the focus must be trapped in this modal itself.
And it should never go behind the modal.
So now the third rule again,
that a user must be able to close this modal,
using escape press.
I'm pressing the key escape and yes, it closed.
So it's good.
Now, one more thing,
which has happened that the focus went right back
to the same button from where the user had started.
So the context has not been lost for the user.
They know that, okay, I had started from here,
I went to the modal, I did something
and now I'm back at this button. I can proceed now.
So this is an example of a good accessible modal,
which we can create.
And let's see how we can achieve these functionalities
using JavaScript.
So in the example section below, in the sample code,
we have an HTML, we have a button
which is going to open the modal
and there is a div which contains all the modal content.
And if you see, I provided it a role of dialogue,
because we want to let the assistive technologies know
that this content is going to be a dialogue.
Let's jump to JavaScript section.
In JavaScript we have,
you summed up the credit selectors to get our modal,
to get our different interactions on the modal,
as well as the button, which is going to open our modal.
Now, let's see what happens when we click
on the open modal button.
So as soon as we click on the open modal button,
three things are happening here.
The first thing is we have a variable
which stores the previous active element
and what with that,
we save that current active element of document,
which was that button,
which opens the modal.
So we store that into this previous active element.
After we had stored it, we toggle it.
It means that we are now putting the modal in front,
we are making it visible.
After that, what we do, the third thing which we do,
that we go through all the focusable elements
of the modal.
If you see here, what we are doing,
we are currently selecting into the modal.
And for my scenario, I only had buttons on the modal.
So I will go ahead and check how many buttons I have.
And I select the first one and put the focus on it.
So I say that, hey, by default when the modal opens,
you have to focus on the first interactive element,
which is the cross icon for us.
Now, when we close the modal using either close button
or the submit button, what we are doing here,
that we are toggling the modal with focus restore.
What does this mean?
Is that first we toggle the modal
to now disappear. We want it to hide.
So we hide it through this.
And then, if you remember
that when we were opening the modal,
we had saved the reference of the button into this variable.
What we do now essentially is we go ahead and focus on it.
So now that button is focused when the modal closes
due to this line of code.
Apart from that,
there is also code of trapping the focus inside the modal
where we are checking on the keydown
so it is attached to keydown event
and we are checking if the user is pressing tab.
And then we see if the combination is shift / tab
or normal tab.
And according to that,
we go ahead and focus the elements.
Then there is one more code for escape.
So if the user will press the escape key,
what will happen?
That we are again,
going to hide the modal and restore the focus
back to the button from the other modal that got open.
And the reference for this is also there
in case you are interested, you can go explore it further.
Then the rule number five, this is our last rule for today.
We should be honoring the user's device settings.
So we are going to see a use case of animations.
Normally, what happens that animations,
this is not like against using animation.
We can use animations for all we want.
Animations really make our websites beautiful
and attractive,
but there are some of the users
who have certain conditions
that they feel uneasy when they see animation
or the flashing content on their screen.
So there is these settings in every operating system
or in every device where we can go ahead
and set if we want to see animation or not.
So if you, for Windows what it is is
that if you type animation
and we get a setting right here.
In the setting by default it's on.
So this means that, okay, I want to see any animations
which occurred in any of our websites which I am accessing.
So let's see an example of how it will affect.
So this is the example for animation.
So if you see now, for now I don't have any preference.
What I want that okay if animations are there,
I should be able to see and that's fine.
We are able to see the animations on our screen.
Now let's say I do not want to see the animation.
So my device settings says that,
okay, turn off the animations on any content
which I see on my windows machine.
So if I refresh again, if you see,
okay it takes a while maybe.
Yes. So if you see now that this animation has stopped.
So we have written a code to honor device settings of users.
So animation is stopped right now. It's still.
So user will not face any kind of issues.
But in this example, this is still going on.
The animation is still going on.
So this is not a very good user experience.
Let's see how we can achieve this through our code.
There are two ways of doing that.
We can achieve it using CSS.
In CSS we have a media query,
which says prefers reduced motion.
So if the user will not have any preference,
what we do inside media query,
we can go ahead and write all our code of animation.
So the styling,
which will attach the animation to any element
on our webpage, that can go inside this media query.
So what this will do
is that if user will have any kind of preference,
this code is not gonna run.
And this CSS is not gonna get applied to our website.
If we want to use JavaScript,
in JavaScript we have a match media API,
and we can check for again,
the same media query, prefers reduced motion.
So this is going to return True
if user has set their device settings,
to say that, hey, I do not want to see any animation.
In that case what we will do,
is we are not going to apply any classes,
but if user has no such settings,
we will go ahead and apply this class, whichever we want.
And it contains all the animation code for us.
So using preferred, reduced motion media query,
we can really use it to detect the device settings of users
and we can help them in getting the more accessible content.
We are done with the rules and now
I've listed down some tools and extensions,
which we can use to see how accessible
our websites really are.
So these are some of the dev tools, extensions,
which we can really use and those are the extensions,
which we can use to test our website accessibility.
I will go and quickly run you through these.
First and foremost,
things which we already have in our dev tools
is the accessibility pane.
So what accessibility pane does is,
that you can go ahead and select any element on your screen
and see what is the accessibility information for it.
So I select it and I go to the accessibility pane.
And if you see,
there are many accessibility information here
and also the tree of accessibility.
This is how the assistive technologies
read our element on our webpage.
So they can go ahead and see it
to see if there are any accessibility issues
with our website.
There is another one which is called Lighthouse.
In Lighthouse what we can do is
that we can select accessibility,
we can select the device for which we want to see,
and we can generate the report for it.
It generates an audit report
for the accessibility of our current webpage.
And it gives you information on what is accessible,
what is not, a score for accessibility
and how you can fix something which is not accessible.
In my case, there is one accessibility issue.
And it's going to tell me how I can fix it.
Also some things which we can manually check on our website
to see if they are still working or not.
And this actually works.
And there is one more, which is called aXe.
So aXe is also an extension,
which we need to add from browser extensions.
This is the extension,
and it also gets added to the dev tools itself.
Here, aXe, it works similar to the Lighthouse.
Then we have Wave, which is an extension of a browser.
So this is Wave extension.
For that what we need to do, right click and Wave this page.
So when I Wave this page,
what it will do,
it is going to give me all the accessibility information
of this page.
And it has very detailed information.
Personally I really like it a lot.
And you can go ahead and check about all the elements,
their information and what they do.
This is really helpful.
So I recommend you to go ahead and check out these tools
and see how your website is doing in terms of accessibility
and fix if possible.
And these are for the testing, for testing our websites.
But now I really believe that we should be thinking
about accessibility from the very start.
So there are some tools which help us detect accessibility
at development phase itself.
So Web Accessibility and webhint
are some of the IDE extensions
so I have added them in my VS Code extension,
and I just wanted to show you
how they help us detect accessibility issues
during the development phase itself.
So I have the extensions installed in my VS Code,
and if you see,
I'm trying to add a click handler on a div.
So it detects that.
Okay there is a click handler
and it's going to tell me
that we should at least specify a role for it
so that the assisted users understand about these things.
And then I have another one,
which is an image and it does not have alt
and alt is really important for accessibility.
So it's going to go ahead and tell me that,
hey, you should add an alt for it.
It gives very good information.
And so what these tools do is they really help
when I'm typing, when I'm coding,
so that I do not write any inaccessible code by mistake.
Although the support which they have is really limited,
but still, it really helps
in some of the major rules of HTML.
So it helps a lot in preventing the inaccessible code,
getting sipped to the production.
Also, there are different plugins
like this one, eslint-plugin for JSX.
What it does that it's obviously for JSX code
as the name suggests.
It's an estlin-plugin and we can configure it.
And whenever we are coding in JSX,
it will give us good information of
what is the accessibility of our current code,
which we are writing.
So to conclude,
we must always consider the users
with wide range of abilities and technologies
when we are coding,
or when we are creating an application or website.
Always use proper semantic HTML wherever possible,
or remember to add that extra code
so that it's accessible for everyone.
We must always manage the focus and keyboard interactivity
of the elements on our webpages or applications.
And always, always, always focus on accessibility,
just like we focus on everything else
on our webpage, websites, applications.
Always code with accessibility in mind.
These are some of the resources which I took reference from
when I was creating this talk.
It also contains the website,
which I used to demo and some Codepen links,
which I've used in the presentation.
I will be sharing this slide after the talk.
You can go through all the links and explore yourself.
I also have an action item for you today.
If you have learned anything from this talk,
I highly encourage you to pass on that learning,
or go ahead and talk with someone or your team mate,
or a friend you are working with,
and you can discuss about accessibility.
And this is something that we need really everyone
to be highly aware of.
So let's all spread this light of awareness.
And so that the world is highly accessible place
for everyone.
Let's all work toward a more inclusive world.
Keep learning everyone, stay safe and thanks a lot.
Any questions, I'm open to questions now.